welcome back to part two of reacting to
my own videos today we're going to focus
mostly on some music videos oh no these
are super super embarrassing I mean I
you know I love music and I feel like
the problem with a lot of these if
there's a lot of things we would record
these and make the lyrics everything the
night before in GarageBand and then film
it in a day the next day we have a
really good time doing it
so much fun no it happened be out that'd
be a great idea for video and then we
would drop whatever we were doing the
rest today
go home planet you over the costume
store we have a little notepad alert
we wouldn't listen to the original saw
hundreds of times
well oh you got Adam Harris eater this
one you've got and Italy Terrace where
do you see this one this was an original
this wasn't even a cover 2010 when we
would go to the beach on vacation I
never end up in America you there may
not go anymore to North Carolina's
personal credit Harris Teeter welcome at
Rockland Al Capone end what are you
doing over there
meet Rachel do you remember that you
made this right yes yeah I was pushing
her in the car and filming I think gonna
talk about a muffin wait till you see it
[Music]
[Music]
before I don't okay I don't know I also
can there's the beach Hemington there's
also a tan setting on my camera that a
strong vibrant gonna make your hair
yellow jeweler oh my god I remember that
tank top I really liked that tank top at
the time mine no mine no no I like I
like cookie cookies for free I'll see
Bree when I'm looking at
wait a minute oh she's gone
that's gross every way I brought wearing
shoes why were you shooting the grocery
store
I don't know but every time I see you
wear shorts I think the price is right
and I think when can we go back because
the 10 years is almost up
you sold us in like a studio apartment
so it's not Malaga now that would be one
bedroom nosy ass is one bedroom yeah
what am I wearing
that's back in style now click oh uh
yeah a romper what's up the kids are
calling it a rupture looks like i'm
pleum not well mm this is 2009
[Music]
you know I feel a little less bad about
you making my voice in the hair video oh
my god how do you know this is 4 million
view the 4 million people have seen that
you should hide you should back down
you should make yourself up species
anymore how they're kidding you filmed
the IKEA green like it a green IKEA
blanket to use as a green screen a
little tiny camera Lugosi pointing shoot
I think we had to go to forever 21 to
try to find you this out we did yeah
you're wearing shorts again could you
have no you might suppose thing is now
like technically imposing it because
I've cat Shaw I want to discover the
hairspray I was trying to be ketchup
there isn't app for that as an American
woman tennis I know it
you actually if that is it I got it you
guys knew where I filmed of that where
did you film it somewhere I listen to
reason good I'll tell you off camera I
live off camera secret tonight so how
long do you think it took you to you're
buying a bra to see it yes by my gosh
I'm sorry but I remember I think this is
why your channel is restricted from much
ah Angeles for my eyes my heart and neck
no oh this is 2010 you should have known
better run
I can't speak because I'm scared it's a
lil we do in our coffee or my site did
you not believe in capitalizing letters
or what's up I don't know there's not
just you patience you're different Kesha
no this is so bad
okay bad babies like what is my vote
view video and I just want to say Rianne
was the inspiration the will.i.am had
seen this video hadn't and I upon you
know we have seen it and I apologized to
him for it if you just like miss Celie
well you are super glossy I remember
that yeah smell of it pink
you still have that pink I don't I wish
I did a loyal you are so glossy hey you
ladies fry tonight you know it looks
like it's Friday hell tonight's the
night looking to get up not you click it
up know can you I said night will pick
it up okay I've got my camera will snap
it off snap up and all my going uses a
flash anymore you and you use that theme
in the previous segment to learn Allison
yeah because each one of those
backgrounds work at like 25 to 45
dollars Wow yo big boss
I need didn't have much money I can buy
a carton full believe the things my eyes
are we living look at old Facebook look
at the tags oh my goodness like man
everything every day it gets better
hashtag hello I think this Oh know
exactly when it can't get any worse
this was the one looks very good true
those as well and still has a limp leg
oh he done the guy photo book I just
seen LEGO pieces that arm you see that
you know it was my fault right I do I
was changing and then I thought someone
was coming in the door so I had like
hurry up to like put my shirt on
I'll give you off here and up scared
knocked over the whole arm and I was
just like oh because they just felt like
how long making cool that's below yes
Joe shot this for me can you look your
hair is a nice color and everything I
like that color it's a very nice color
it's about the same as it is now it's a
little lighter tone I shouldn't let's
react to got it from 2012 oh my gosh hmm
that's insane
that is absolutely insane
oh just smooth with us I remember I saw
my friend from home we're filling out an
issue we saw so many people so many that
we knew this day Nathan do you need
names another shoot I think we just I
think it what oh my old I feel out
that's when I have my TV on now I like
to Mickelson pull the top necklace my
hair and I came out yeah and I paralyzed
okay I remember this mm-hmm
let's pie cackling Wow well you really
maybe work for a highly realistic
decorating laughs you laugh you laugh
down oh oh my god wait there's another
one
it's Taylor Swift it's all right This Is
It this is what I meant movement and
that Nathan salt we even choose a bunch
of my videos for me now when allah the
cooking one $2.00 hen a 2010 we met him
on the street and he said hey I should
videos like my guy right well we're
never going to end that we're making
stranger danger I remember that dress as
well he did but you think you keep you
bring out that pink guitar I swear I'm
gonna hit you with it do not bring out a
pink guitar I'll hit you this is so
great it was got this car it's got a
good colored yeah hey you're wearing
tank tops in I don't wash me pink up
here like I'm going to get into tank
tops this year 2010 years oh my gosh is
about a thing you want to be crazy 7
years from now you're like Johnny you
keep on go back there nice in Hey look I
never took this off this is cool
7 years from now we're gonna be like why
was that girl wearing a hole why did she
have holes in her shirt
why was she doing this thing she was
doing I can't believe she wearing yoga
pants will example kind of camp what are
the pants the future can be like the
future pants what I think the laundry
outside what are the views your pants
gonna be what am I going to be wearing
in ten warriors I think we need to
create future skews your pants I love it
swear don't don't forget your belt okay
my thing it dirty it's already mine
mm-hmm oh thank your fans well this is
trash hey you're wearing the shirt that
I had on another music video I didn't
let her only why am i hanging up clothes
do you remember this
yes I will never forget this look at you
you should try to be so like sensual
sensual yes I'm trying to huge that
jewel here let's see you sort by newest
to think should do month ago Oh God
I don't like laughing so much better
alright you wish I could stuff like this
this is cringe that's what you want
alright you get the picture alright now
you vampire in this one vampire Ross
gosh I remember that have you seen this
2010 wait you need joshing mm yeah oh my
gosh because I met it at the first
VidCon I'm wearing and I just being
shirt get Josh's part is really good you
might think that a bear plan a summer
vitals are but not its value looks like
Stephenie Meyer business which is
incredible
yeah God isn't good you should copy this
link now you're like just run all week
so so good you're a head banger holding
this far I mean please you tell her oh
my part to that incredible got a wooden
Sykes gonna do some baking so you dip my
finger done zipper in the mixing yellow
line and get it up oh oh one but
whatever we went to uh we eventually
cost you a store and then we had to mold
these space teams together I remember I
we not only I was here but I feel like I
wait my long Brehon with her do you guys
enjoy Hawaii that your first TMZ fixture
ever was I got stopped by KMZ at the
airport and they were like okay just
seem to see Versailles like hi and I
smile that freaking vent bangs on
because it was a Halloween Halloween it
was crazy I kind of happened thank you
really mm like mine are very ears are
yeah a little bit more I can't watch
anymore
you got to make a go I mean Josh is part
with the crowd I mean there's so many
more music videos I can't even believe
it we need part three
here's my go out showing some skin I
felt super uncomfortable from on the
skin skin I miss College ID so much yeah
good show nothing but trash you did
here's one so that fake that's fake I
think it's a carrot that's definitely
big this is real this is real this is
real yeah really long that's not real
nothing although I'm actually probably
almost that long isn't it yeah well this
is a nice video is it over yet
no I'm done okay okay that's it that is
reacting part 2 there's so many more
music videos and cringe-worthy content
that I can react to so let me know if
you guys have any favourites that you'd
like us to react to and I will see you
guys in my next video make sure to check
out channel channel and if you missed
the first version of this I'll put a
result in the description and a card at
the end of this video and you can click
the little I and this will be over there
there's a lot of win everywhere and if
you don't find it then you can't mine
yet like see I'm sorry I'm sorry for
what I do like to apologize it's too
late apologize it's too late you know
what the most embarrassing thing is like
doing these parodies and then meeting
these people later in life it's super
embarrassing catchin him nay I had a
problem once where I did it until I am
Oh Katy Perry Oh
[Music]
I don't wanna be but here's the thing
what you thought has ever lasted it was
to the first but eventually could skew
between you did everything you could